* Hupen *
* Fliessender Indie-Rock-Song *
# Don't look at me like this,
hun, don't be upset.
# What a wonderful day.
# Don't be mad at me
because I feel alright.
# I can't be happy
if you're not alright.
# Don't worry
cause I really feel alright.
# I go to the USA.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Die sich drehenden Rotorblätter
der Windturbinen
scheinen Randy vorwärtszutreiben,
auf der Strasse
nach Desert Hot Springs,
mehr als 2 Std.
von Los Angeles entfernt.
Eine Wellnessoase,
bescheidene Cousine von Palm Springs,
dem Heim der Stars.
Dieser Ort heisst Desert Hot Springs
und ist sehr bekannt
für seine Thermalquellen.
Früher war das
der Lieblingskurort von Al Capone.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Als ich die Schweiz verliess,
bin ich ohne Retourticket losgezogen
und wusste nicht, wie lange ich
in Los Angeles bleiben würde.
Aber ich dachte,
dass ich bei meiner Pensionierung
in die Schweiz zurückkehren würde.
Als ich diesen Ort entdeckte,
wo viele Rentner leben, merkte ich,
dass das hier
auch eine Möglichkeit ist.
Da ich ja jetzt mein Haus habe,
könnte ich mir vorstellen,
hier zu bleiben.
Ich komme nicht nur am Wochenende
her, sondern wann immer ich kann.
Wie ein moderner Franz von Assisi
kümmert sich der Riese
mit dem grossen Herzen um die Vögel.
Das ist der heilige Franziskus,
der Beschützer aller Tiere.
Ich habe ihn
hier im Garten platziert,
so kann er die Tiere draussen,
aber auch meine Katzen beschützen,
wenn ich nicht da bin.
Das ist meine
American-Football-Souvenirsammlung.
Mein erster Helm von meiner ersten
Mannschaft, den Lugano Seagulls.
Hier ein Bild der ersten Schweizer
Meisterschaft. Das bin ich.
Das ist der Siegerring,
den wir 1994 gewonnen haben.
Und vor drei Jahren wurde ich
in die Hall of Fame aufgenommen,
in den Kreis
der berühmtesten Spieler.
Das ist die grösste Ehre,
die mir während meiner gesamten
sportlichen Laufbahn zuteil wurde.
Das ist die einzige Erinnerung
an meine Mutter.
Ihr Ehering und die Kette,
die sie zu ihrer Hochzeit trug.
Meine Eltern
sind beide 2011 gestorben.
Meine Mutter hatte einen Hirntumor.
Jedes Mal,
wenn wieder etwas passierte,
kam ich in die Schweiz zurück.
Mein Vater starb an Weihnachten
im selben Jahr.
Er war Raucher und hatte schon immer
viele gesundheitliche Probleme.
Und als meine Mutter starb,
wollte er nicht allein weiterleben.
Also ist er auch von uns gegangen.
Der Tod meiner Eltern war
die schwierigste Zeit meines Lebens.
* Kindergeschrei *
Im Herzen Hollywoods,
nur einen Katzensprung
vom Sunset Boulevard entfernt,
befindet sich die Show Gallery,
die normalerweise
v.a. Fotografie ausstellt.
Francesca trifft
ihre Künstlerfreundinnen,
mit denen sie eine Gruppenausstellung
mit einem vielsagenden Titel
präsentieren wird.
Les Amoureuses,
das sind wir vier Liebenden:
Olivia Fougeirol, Francesca
Gabbiani, Marie Peter-Toltz
und ich, Josephine Wister Faure.
Wir machen in der Show Gallery
eine Ausstellung.
Margot hat uns eingeladen,
ein Gruppenprojekt
zum Thema Liebe zu machen,
und wir haben ihm den Namen
Les Amoureuses gegeben.
* Fliessende, elektronische Musik *
Wenn wir
noch mehr Schaden anrichten wollen,
schütten wir Farbe
über den Cadavre exquis,
unser gefaltetes Gruppenbild.
Habt ihr euch alle für eine Arbeit
für die Ausstellung entschieden?
Also ich nehme eine Büste
von Mathieu, meinem Mann.
Da ich ja zwei Ideen hatte,
möchte ich eine Performance machen.
Ich möchte Hostien
mit Bildern bedrucken.
Und danach esse ich
die Bilder meiner Liebsten.
Ich werde das Gegenteil
von Liebenden darstellen.
Was ich mache,
hat gewisse Parallelen
mit Pasolinis Film
"Die 120 Tage von Sodom",
der ja Themen wie Folter oder
die schrecklichen Dinge behandelt,
die Menschen widerfahren können,
wenn sie beim Sex miteinander oder
etwas Verbotenem erwischt werden.
Was mich bei Gruppenausstellungen
interessiert,
sind die Dinge, die wir
im Rahmenprogramm veranstalten.
Wir kreieren ein kleines Fanmagazin,
mit verschiedenen Cadavres exquis.
Wir werden Partys und Performances
veranstalten.
All die Dinge, die wir rund
um die Ausstellung organisieren,
sind spannend,
weil wir komplett freie Hand haben.
Boby Lapointe
hat viel mit Liebe zu tun.
"Verstehe es, wer will,
das ist alles für Schwule."
"Er weiss, worauf ich stehe,
nämlich auf einen Schwanz."
Das macht Lust, Schüttelreime
zu schreiben wie Boby Lapointe.
Und das habe ich auch genommen.
Wir können uns
davon inspirieren lassen.
Das sind alles Flyer
im Stil der Punkbands aus L.A.
Wir verfolgen
kein kommerzielles Ziel,
deshalb müssen wir uns
nicht wirklich darum kümmern,
Anklang zu finden.
Wir können einfach das tun,
was uns interessiert.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Und die Frauen?
Die Frauen machen mich wahnsinnig.
Sie machen mich total verrückt.
Aber ich habe nie geheiratet,
ich war immer unabhängig.
Ich brauche keine, die mir
vorschreibt, wie ich zu leben habe.
Hier sind meine Schlüssel.
Du kannst einen Blick
ins Haus werfen. Bis gleich.
I'll see you later.
- Thank you.
Du musst mehrere Freundinnen haben,
nicht nur eine. Das ist die Lösung.
Drei bis vier, einfach mehrere.
Das geht, wenn sie deine Situation
nachvollziehen können.
Man muss ihnen nichts
von den anderen Frauen erzählen.
Es reicht, ihnen zu erklären,
dass man sehr beschäftigt ist.
Aber wenn ich
mit ihnen zusammen bin,
lasse ich sie spüren,
dass sie mir wichtig sind.
Das heisst nicht,
dass ich leichtfertig bin,
aber für mich ist es besser.
Beziehungen mit verschiedenen
Frauen - für mich stimmt das so.
Allen Liebenden
ist ein bestimmter Tag gewidmet:
der Valentinstag.
Es mit Blumen zu sagen, ist gut.
Besser noch ist es, sich zu schützen.
Der Aids-Screening-Bus
ist auf dem UCLA-Campus,
um auf die Gefahren hinzuweisen.
Wann hast du das Rockers verlassen?
- So gegen 1 Uhr.
Es gibt eine App für 5 $,
mit der kannst du das Schlangestehen
vor dem Club umgehen.
Was, dafür bezahlst du?
- Ja.
Die Schlange reicht manchmal
bis zum Parkplatz.
Hast du am Samstag was vor?
Ich glaube, ich werde lernen.
Das sage ich immer,
aber ich halte mich
meist nicht daran.
Na ja, mal sehen. Wir haben
sehr unterschiedliche Zeitpläne.
Es ist ein kleiner Raum,
und weil wir selten zur selben Zeit
zu Hause sind, klappt es gut.
Es kommt nie vor, dass wir alle drei
gleichzeitig im Raum sind.
Wenn das passiert ... wow!
Ja, wir finden es toll,
wenn wir alle zusammen sind.
Das kommt viel zu selten vor.
Es ist sehr teuer.
1'400 Fr. im Monat
für dieses kleine Zimmer,
das ich mit zwei Personen teile.
Aber immerhin ist das Essen in-
begriffen, zwei Mahlzeiten pro Tag.
Aber ohne Essen
sind es immer noch 1'200 Fr.
Wir haben kein eigenes Badezimmer,
das müssen wir mit allen teilen.
Andererseits ist es wirklich super,
mit den anderen Studenten zusammen-
zuleben und gemeinsam zu essen.
Hier hat man immer Leute um sich.
Bye, I'm going to class.
- See you.
"Frau fünf vor zwölf" beendet
ihre Prüfungsvorbereitungen.
Es gibt einen Professor,
der uns Folgendes gesagt hat:
"Das Problem in Nordkorea ist,
dass sie alles verbieten."
"Sie verbieten z.B. Feuerwaffen,
anstatt den Leuten
einfach beizubringen,
nicht auf ihre Mitmenschen
zu schiessen."
Na ja, es ist etwas seltsam,
dass er dieses Beispiel bringt,
weil Feuerwaffen nur in den
Vereinigten Staaten erlaubt sind.
Und das funktioniert hier
ja nicht gerade gut.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
* Fliessende, elektronische Musik *
Mission impossible
für Roger und seinen Kunden Aaron?
Sie fliegen nach San Francisco,
um endlich die Baugenehmigung
für das Projekt zu bekommen,
gegen das sich die Nachbarn
zur Wehr gesetzt haben.
Sie sind zur letzten öffentlichen
Anhörung, auf die sie Anspruch haben,
vorgeladen worden.
Ein wunderschöner Tag!
Oakland, San Francisco.
- Oakland, das ist übel.
Ich weiss,
ich möchte nicht hier wohnen.
(Mann am Telefon) What's the status?
Es ist die letzte Phase
dieser Scheiss-Anhörung,
die letzte Chance,
Einsprache zu erheben -
und genau das haben sie gemacht.
Sie machen sich Sorgen
um die Rohrleitungen
oder um den Weg,
der übers Grundstück führt.
Ich habe ihnen gesagt,
dass dort niemand wohnt
und dass sie die Parzelle
seit 20 Jahren illegal betreten.
Verdammte Idioten!
Die Hydranten müssen
auf dieser Seite sein, genau da.
Die Sonne
geht gleich da drüben unter.
Du wirst
einen schönen Sonnenuntergang haben.
Von Richmond County hat man Ausblick
auf die Bucht von San Francisco.
Das Quartier ist bekannt
für seine konservativen Anwohner.
Die Nachbarn
haben Einsprache erhoben,
obwohl wir alles so gemacht haben,
wie sie es wollten.
Heute gibt es ein Public Hearing,
wir müssen also vorbeigehen,
den Case noch mal präsentieren.
Und dann wird es
hoffentlich approved,
denn die bestehenden Einsprachen
haben keine base, keinen Grund.
Das ist nicht etwas, das einen
impact haben sollte, theoretisch.
Ein Freund von mir
hat uns einander vorgestellt,
nachdem ich ein Anwesen
in Studio City gekauft hatte.
Ich sah,
dass Roger ein Rockstar ist.
Ich war damals selber
in einer Rockband und dachte,
dass wir uns gut verstehen würden.
Ich mag
seine schlichte Linienführung,
diese Mischung
aus modern und zeitgenössisch.
Das ist sehr europäisch
mit einem kalifornischen Touch,
weil er den Ozean
und das Segeln liebt.
Einer der Opponenten
zeigt sich umgehend.
So läuft das aber nicht.
Wir werden
so rasch wie möglich anfangen,
aber nicht,
bevor wir die Bewilligung haben.
Wenn wir die definitive Bewilligung
haben, legen wir los.
Wenn nur nicht
diese idiotischen Einsprachen wären.
Für die, die die Einsprachen erhoben
haben, sind sie nicht albern.
Nicht wirklich.
- Doch, sicher.
Wenn sie gelesen
und zur Kenntnis genommen hätten,
was im Gesetz steht,
hätten sie keine Einsprache erhoben.
Der Ingenieur
ist mit den Plänen schon fertig,
und es ist alles in Ordnung.
Mal sehen, wie es heute Abend läuft.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
* Donnern *
Nein, ich fahre.
Nicht nur bei ihrem Haus,
auch bei Dora und Pasqual selbst
ist ein Check-up angesagt
vor der Rückkehr in die Schweiz.
Die Interstate 5 Richtung Süden.
Nimm die 405, nicht die 5.
Wir fahren zu meinem Arzt,
Dr. Gary Feldman.
Ich muss einmal im Monat hingehen,
weil ich an dieser Studie teilnehme
für ...
Wie sagt man auf Deutsch -
painkillers?
Schmerztabletten.
Wir haben hier diese Opioid-Krise
und es ist noch nichts wirklich gut.
Schmerzmittel, Opiate -
sie sind das Sinnbild des Notstandes
im amerikanischen Gesundheitswesen.
265'000 Tote in vier Jahren.
Kalifornien belegt
eine makabre Spitzenposition.
Mehr als 2 Mio. Amerikaner sind
von solchen Medikamenten abhängig.
Pasqual ist einer von ihnen.
Heute trägt er
Kompressionshandschuhe -
nach 18 Operationen
hat er ständig und überall Schmerzen.
Dora hat zugestimmt, für ihren Mann
neue Behandlungsmethoden zu testen.
Aber auch sie leidet an der Hüfte.
Wir hoffen, dass der Antikörper,
den wir gespritzt haben,
die Schmerzen lindert
und Sie keine opiumhaltigen Medika-
mente wie Morphium mehr benötigen.
Aber er nimmt die ganze Zeit
solche Medikamente.
Das Problem
in den Vereinigten Staaten ist,
dass wir zu viel opiumhaltige
Medikamente konsumieren.
Als ich anfing zu praktizieren,
waren wir sehr zurückhaltend
mit dieser Art von Rezepten.
Aber dann wuchs der Druck enorm,
Schmerzen
besser in Schach zu halten,
und die wirksamsten Medikamente
waren eben diese Opiate.
Deshalb haben wir sie dann
extrem häufig verschrieben.
Viele dieser Opiate wurden
auch auf der Strasse verkauft.
Er hat mir buchstäblich
zweimal das Leben gerettet.
Ich war in einer
sehr schlechten Verfassung.
Man hatte mir
eine Morphiumpumpe implantiert,
eines Tages gab es aber
keinen Nachschub mehr.
Ich hatte Entzugserscheinungen.
Ich habe ihn angerufen, er kam
hierher und er gab mir Medikamente,
um die Schmerzen
der Entzugserscheinungen zu lindern.
Ohne Pasqual wäre es mir nie in
den Sinn gekommen, hier mitzumachen.
Aber ich sehe, wie er leidet.
Und diese Schmerzen die ganze Zeit.
Ich unterstütze jegliche Forschung
auf diesem Gebiet.
It's vibrating.
Ich glaube,
sie tut es aus Mitgefühl,
was ich wirklich sehr schätze.
Aber wenn du selbst nicht betroffen
bist, kannst du nicht viel tun,
weil du die Schmerzen nicht spürst
und nicht weisst,
was diese emotional und psychisch
in einem auslösen.
Also tust du einfach dein Bestes.
Schau, was die machen!
They're fixing up the ...
Das ist lustig.
Der heutige Lehrgang an der UCLA:
Lernen, auf dem Wasser zu gehen.
Hier sind die Leute
nicht an Regen gewöhnt.
Das ist wohl der Grund,
weshalb es hier nichts gibt,
was für Regentage geeignet ist.
Alles ist aus Beton.
Ich habe diese Schuhe angezogen,
weil alle meine Turnschuhe
vom Gehen auf den überschwemmten
Trottoirs nass sind.
Auf dem Campus
bilden sich überall Rinnsale.
Diese Woche
sind die Midterm-Prüfungen.
Ich hatte bereits am Montag
eine Prüfung.
Ich neige dazu, mich zu stressen,
und habe wohl nicht
das beste Zeitmanagement.
Ich habe bis 3 Uhr morgens gelernt.
Laurianes Prüfung konzentriert sich
auf einen mathematischen Bereich,
die Spieltheorie:
das Zusammenspiel von Entscheidungen
zwischen Individuen.
Ein Test, der beginnt wie ein Spiel.
Hat jemand eine Prüfungsaufgabe,
wo schriftliche Notizen draufstehen?
Zu Frage 1?
(Frau) Yeah, I definitely have one.
Look and see if you've got
a correction on question 1.
We should have two, not just one.
Hier sind die Korrekturen:
Bei Frage 1 BY gilt 5,25
und CY 0,25.
Viel Glück.
* Lachen *
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Mitten in der Prüfung sagte uns
der Prof: "Aufgabe 6 ist unlösbar."
"Ihr könnt sie also streichen
und müsst sie nicht lösen."
Und das, nachdem ich während 10 Min.
vergeblich versucht hatte,
die Aufgabe zu lösen.
Es gab noch eine andere Aufgabe,
die mir unlösbar erschien.
Ich weiss nicht, ob das auch
ein Fehler des Profs war.
Deshalb habe ich
die Aufgabe angepasst -
ich habe die Matrix übernommen
und die Zahlen verändert
und die Aufgabe dann so gelöst,
wie ich es für richtig hielt.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
wie das herauskommen wird.
Es war keine seriöse Prüfung.
Ich weiss nicht, mal sehen.
* Treibende, elektronische Musik *
Guten Abend, meine Damen und Herren,
willkommen.
In San Francisco
unterziehen sich Roger und Aaron
der alles entscheidenden Prüfung.
Zehn Nachbarn
haben Einsprache erhoben.
Als Nachbarin möchte ich meine
wichtigsten Anliegen anbringen:
die Sicherheit
und den Zugang zur Strasse.
Die Kommission wird
über ihre Relevanz befinden.
Roger tritt ihnen zum dritten
und letzten Mal entgegen.
Alles oder nichts.
Was die Einspruch erhebenden
Parteien anbringen,
sind Dinge, die im vergangenen Jahr
verhandelt wurden.
Wir sind
auf alle Forderungen eingegangen.
Wir haben z.B.
einen Nachbarn in 16 Belvedere,
der sich über die Grösse der Fenster
beschwert hat.
Also haben wir
die Fenster verkleinert.
Beim zweiten Treffen hat er gesagt:
"Ich will keine Fenster."
Also haben wir
die Fenster ganz entfernt.
Wir sind
auf alle Wünsche eingegangen.
Mir wird die Aussicht
auf die Stadt San Francisco verbaut,
was Auswirkungen
auf mein Anwesen hat.
Dadurch wird es abgewertet.
Wir versperren ihr nicht
die Aussicht.
Sie hat immer noch Meersicht
und Aussicht auf die Brücke.
Im Eck ist das Haus
ein klein wenig in ihrem Blickfeld.
Ja, beim seitlichen Fenster ihres
Hauses geht die Aussicht verloren,
aber im Gegenzug haben wir
unsere Fenster entfernt,
damit sie nicht
in unser Haus sehen muss.
Ihr Haus und ihr Fenster waren halt
schon da, da kann man nichts machen.
Ich realisiere Projekte
auf der ganzen Welt.
Das hier
ist sehr frustrierend für mich,
weil ich mit guten Absichten
an die Dinge herangehe,
um mit den Quartierbewohnern
ein tolles Projekt zu verwirklichen.
Und alles, was ich bekomme,
ist ein Schlag nach dem anderen.
Es läuft so: "Versuchen wir dies,
versuchen wir das,
verhindern wir dies,
verhindern wir das."
Aber irgendwann
muss man einen Punkt machen.
So kann es nicht weitergehen.
Deshalb bitte ich Sie,
meinen Antrag zu akzeptieren.
Kommen wir zur Abstimmung!
Yes.
- No.
- Yes. - Yes.
Thanks very much.
Vier zu eins - Roger hat gewonnen.
Es ist gut gelaufen.
Es dauerte länger als gedacht.
Es ist jetzt doch 22.30 Uhr.
Aber ... whatever!
Jetzt essen wir noch einen Burger.
Es ist das letzte Mal,
dass Dora diesen Weg einschlägt.
Ihr Abenteuer in Los Angeles
geht zu Ende.
Monica, Doras Immobilienmaklerin,
ist auch ihre Schülerin.
Das Haus ihrer Lehrerin zu verkaufen,
ist ein Tanz, den Monica beherrscht.
Was nehme ich aus Los Angeles mit?
den Sonnenschein,
die freundlichen Menschen.
Sie sind sehr freundlich,
sehr liebevoll.
Sie können lachen.
In der Schweiz lacht man nicht so
viel wie in Amerika und v.a. in L.A.
Jede nimmt eine Blume.
Hinter den Kulissen
perfektionieren die Schüler
die Hommage
an ihre geliebte Tanzlehrerin.
Oh my god!
Thank you. Wow!
* Jubel, Kreischen *
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin
bei meiner eigenen Beerdigung dabei.
Wir lieben dich, Dora.
Sie ist süss
wie Schweizer Schokolade.
Sie ist pünktlich
wie eine Schweizer Uhr.
Sie ist scharfsinnig
wie ein Schweizer Messer.
Right, Dora?
(Alle) Dora, Dora, Dora!
A big hug, everybody.
Come on, big hug! Everybody.
* Tragende Musik: "Non, je ne
regrette rien" von Edith Piaf *
# Non, rien de rien,
# non, je ne regrette rien.
Ich habe die Schweiz
mit 20 verlassen.
Jetzt mit fast 73 Jahren
bin ich immer noch Schweizerin.
Es ist Zeit, nach Hause zu gehen.
# Non, rien de rien,
# non, je ne regrette rien.
# C'est paye, balaye, oublie,
# je me fous du passe.
Malibu: Der Strand,
an dem Pamela Anderson in "Baywatch"
in Zeitlupe entlanglief,
hat sich fest im kollektiven
Unterbewusstsein eingeprägt.
Wow!
Wir sind in Point Dume, Malibu,
um zu surfen.
Aber ich muss noch den Pool putzen.
Wir wollen ihn anschliessen,
weil das Wasser noch sehr kalt ist.
Hier ist man wirklich auf dem Land.
Es ist wie ein kleines Dorf mit
einem Strand und einem Supermarkt.
Das war's auch schon,
sonst gibt es hier nichts.
Das ist einfach super.
Typisch Kalifornien.
Das ist unser Familienhaus,
wir putzen es, wir reparieren es,
wir machen alles, was nötig ist.
Und v.a. kommen wir,
wann immer möglich,
um am Wochenende hier zu relaxen.
Heute hat uns Josephine begleitet.
Ich bin so happy, dass sie hier ist.
Wir machen uns einen ruhigen Morgen.
Ja, wir stehen uns nah, aber
wir stehen auch den anderen nah.
Unsere Kinder sind ein Herz
und eine Seele, mehr Herz als Seele,
obwohl, ganz sicher sind wir nicht.
Wir haben
enorm viele Gemeinsamkeiten,
wie die Kunst, das Muttersein,
das Managen von Familie und Job -
und das bei einem Lohn, der in
Abhängigkeit der Verkäufe variiert.
Das ist manchmal
schon etwas stressig,
deshalb versuchen wir,
uns gegenseitig zu helfen.
Wir können uns verteidigen
oder Spass haben.
Milo, Tristan!
Den hier, was meinst du?
Denkst du nicht,
dass das Wasser zu kalt ist?
Der Neoprenanzug reicht.
Vorwärts! Los geht's!
* Treibende Musik *
Wow!
* Dynamische Elektromusik *
Das sind
sehr schöne Familienmomente.
Wir versuchen, ihnen ein Heim
zu geben, wo sie sich wohlfühlen.
Das ihnen erlaubt,
Selbstwertgefühl zu entwickeln,
das ihnen ermöglicht,
das zu tun, was sie möchten,
und auch daran zu glauben.
Meine Eltern leben in Genf
und ich wünsche mir,
ich könnte sie öfter besuchen.
Wir skypen jeden Sonntag,
ich sehe sie also trotzdem
einmal die Woche live.
Ab und zu rufe ich sie
auch während der Woche an,
wenn ich Neuigkeiten
zu gewissen Themen vor Ort brauche.
Und ich versuche,
etwas häufiger auf Besuch zu gehen.
Der Umgang mit dem Alter
kann schwierig sein,
auch für jüngere Leute, die sich
um die Älteren kümmern müssen.
Ich möchte gerne weiter hier wohnen.
Ich habe plötzlich Hunger,
ich gehe etwas essen. Tschüss.
Aus den Augen, aus dem Sinn.
Beat Generation, Hippies,
Sex, Drugs and Rock 'n' Roll.
Die Revolution
gehört längst der Vergangenheit an.
In Los Angeles geben heute Sportler,
Yogis und Veganer den Ton an.
* Fiepen *
Who's a good dog?
Mitten im Winter.
Wir sind hier in Kalifornien,
kein Schnee weit und breit.
Nur ein bisschen Regen.
Immer neue,
unvorhergesehene Arbeiten,
bevor das Haus
endlich verkauft werden kann.
Pasqual bereitet sich geistig
darauf vor, selbst Hand anzulegen.
Möchten Sie etwas essen, Jose?
Nein, danke.
Machen Sie bitte die Tür zu.
Close the door? Okay.
* Geschäftige Musik *
The screw.
It doesn't matter.
- If you think so.
No, that's the screwdriver.
I'll bite you in a minute!
Okay, I leave you alone.
Es ist gut für ihn,
wenn er etwas macht.
Aber ich fürchte,
dass er morgen nicht gehen kann,
weil er
noch mehr Schmerzen haben wird.
Is it working?
Am Anfang
wollten wir das nicht tun.
Ich habe all das getan,
was Monica mir gesagt hat.
Nachdem ich mit ihr geredet hatte
und nicht sehr zufrieden war,
bin ich ins Internet - deshalb sitze
ich die ganze Zeit vor dem Tablet.
Die Häuser,
die neu gestrichen sind ...
Wir haben auch neue Fenster.
... die verkaufen sich besser.
Die Leute wollen
gleich einziehen können.
Ich sehe hier im Internet,
dass man für 10'000 $ Investment
20'000 $ herausschlagen kann.
* Geschäftige Musik *
Tada! One lump or two?
Jungs, seid nicht so kreativ!
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Randy besucht seine beste Freundin
Luciana, die ganz in der Nähe wohnt.
Dank ihrer Hilfe konnte er
sein Haus in Hot Springs kaufen.
Luciana!
- Benvenuti. Ciao, Randy.
Come stai?
Ich habe Bier mitgebracht.
Dieses Jahr hat der Super Bowl
einen Tessiner Touch.
Luciana und ihr Freund
haben Randy
und ihren Freund Maurillio
zum grossen American-Football-Finale
eingeladen.
Mein Traum war es,
nach Asien zu gehen.
Margarita.
Mein erster Mann
hatte in Los Angeles gelebt
und war hier zur Schule gegangen.
Als wir uns entschieden,
zurückzukehren,
sind wir nach Los Angeles gekommen.
Ich dachte: "Los Angeles, na ja!"
Aber ich bin
wegen meines Mannes geblieben.
Aber um ehrlich zu sein,
hat es mir dann auf Anhieb gefallen.
Luciana ist sogar Präsidentin des
Tessiner Klubs Pro Ticino geworden,
wo sie sich kennengelernt haben.
Nichts gegen die Schweiz,
aber dort ist es nicht möglich,
sich Netzwerke aufzubauen
wie in Los Angeles oder New York.
Ich will nicht mehr so oft
in die Schweiz wie früher,
denn nach einem Tag dort
denkt man: "Pff ..."
Das kenne ich.
Nach eineinhalb Wochen
wollte ich wieder nach Hause.
Andiamo!
Los,
lasst uns den Super Bowl schauen!
Ich habe mich wirklich sehr gut
integriert in "unserem" Kalifornien.
Das ist jetzt unser Zuhause.
Das Tessin ist schön, ein wirklich
schöner Flecken Erde für Besuche.
Es ist auch schön,
dort aufzuwachsen,
aber Amerika hat mir
viel mehr gebracht.
Die Erfahrungen, die ich hier in den
letzten 28 Jahren gesammelt habe,
sind unvergesslich.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Come on!
Dai!
He played very good.
- The defense is great.
Crazy.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
* Treibende Musik *
Marina del Rey
ist vollständig von L.A. umschlossen.
Hello.
- Hoi.
Hoi, alles in Ordnung?
- Ja.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Was machst du?
Ich muss noch etwas
für Reto fertig machen.
Bist du dann bereit?
- Ja.
Go for a walk?
- Ja, jetzt ist es noch schön.
Was machst du?
Ich muss das ganze Haus
etwas verschieben.
I just need to shift everything over
and ...
Wird das nicht zu klein?
- It's not a problem.
Das ist der Pool.
Hier habe ich eine Wand,
auf die man Movies projizieren kann.
Man kann das Fenster öffnen,
im Wohnzimmer sitzen
und draussen Movies schauen.
Ich habe während 19 Jahren
für das Schweizer Konsulat
in Los Angeles gearbeitet.
Ich habe im März ...
Ich weiss es noch genau, ich habe
am 13. März 2000 angefangen.
Leider habe ich Ende 2018 aufgehört,
weil das Konsulat geschlossen wurde.
Davor hatten wir halt einen Ort,
wo wir mit den Schweizer residents
tolle Sachen machen konnten.
Eine Plattform für alle.
Sei es Kultur, sei es Business.
Wir haben versucht,
die Menschen zusammenzubringen,
und das haben wir jetzt
leider nicht mehr.
Es ist doch ein starkes Minus,
auch für die Schweiz,
dass wir nicht mehr so präsent sind.
Okay, hast du ihn ausgemacht?
Cool, let's go!
Auf der anderen Seite
hat es auch noch einen.
* Fliessende, elektronische Musik *
Wir arbeiten jetzt am Visum,
also an der Green Card.
Sobald ich diese habe,
ist meine Perspektive,
bei Roger einzusteigen.
Grandiose Perspektive!
- Nicht wahr?
Er ist der Designer in der Familie
und ich mache
die Administration, PR ...
... Kaffee.
Kaffee machen.
- Ich bringe den Kaffee, okay.
Lunch holen.
- Lunch holen? Okay, gut.
Aber jetzt wird es kühl.
Nicht?
- Nicht so schlimm.
Es gibt kältere Orte. In der Schweiz
hat es heute geschneit.
Ach ja, stimmt!
Ach ja,
die Familie hat Fotos geschickt.
Mit Schnee im Garten.
Ich möchte gerne
irgendwann in die Schweiz zurück.
Ja, wir müssen schauen,
wie wir das dann machen.
Roger?
Vielleicht wenn ich mal alt bin.
Aber heute und morgen stimmt es.
Mir gefällt es hier
und das Leben hat sich eingerichtet.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
in der Schweiz zu leben.
Aber nicht heute und morgen.
Als Architekt geht man ja
nie richtig in Pension, also ...
... not an option.
- Oh?
Oh? Hast du das nicht
im fine print gelesen.
Nein!
In Los Angeles alt zu sein,
ist schwierig.
It's not really a town to be old.
Im Moment stimmt es.
Wenn ich älter bin, ist es
vielleicht anders. I don't know!
Wir sind aber
keine spring chickens mehr.
Du vielleicht.
Hey!
- I'm good.
Salut.
- Hello.
Wie geht's dir?
- Gut. Und dir?
Lauriane gönnt sich endlich
einen freien Abend -
mit Anja, einer anderen
Austauschstudentin aus Genf.
Wie bist du gekommen?
- Ich bin mit dem Bus gekommen.
Es hat mehr als 1 Std. gedauert,
1 1/4 Std.
Und dazu dieser Verkehr.
Schrecklich, diese Stadt!
Wenn man irgendwo hingehen will,
braucht man Zeit.
Von der UCLA nach Los Feliz
dauert es 45 Min.
Lausanne-Genf,
nur um einen Burger zu essen.
* Karaoke aus der Bar *
# Oh, I just can't wait to be king.
Es macht mich glücklich, was
ich hier an der Uni erleben darf.
Ja, das ist echt was anderes.
Das Leben spielt sich
v.a auf dem Campus ab.
Und die Profs binden uns mehr
in den Unterricht ein.
Das bringt Abwechslung.
- Einverstanden.
Aber es ist hier verschulter -
wir müssen Arbeiten einreichen,
um sicherzustellen,
dass wir wirklich lernen.
Man bemuttert uns. Man muss
Präsenzlisten unterschreiben.
Und es zählt. Gehst du zur Vorle-
sung, bekommst du eine bessere Note.
In Genf geht man einfach
zur Vorlesung - oder auch nicht.
Ich würde gerne ein ganzes Jahr
hier studieren, aber ich kann nicht.
Hier hat man das Gefühl,
dass irgendwie alles möglich ist.
Geht dir das auch so?
In der Schweiz ist alles mehr ...
Man muss sich sehr anpassen.
Ja, hier kannst du
noch Abenteuer erleben.
# Can you feel the love tonight?
In Los Angeles
ist das Abenteuer paradox:
Wer die Freiheit kosten will, muss
durch die Einschränkungen navigieren.
Die Realität ist leicht zu lesen,
aber schwierig zu entschlüsseln.
# Believe the very best.
Wie viele Angebote erwartest du?
- Zwei.
Das ist nicht die Anzahl,
die wir erhalten haben.
Heute machen wir
etwas Kollaboratives.
Los, mach ihm Füsse!
In all den Jahren habe ich mir
schon alles Mögliche gebrochen.
Die Finger, das Knie.
Ich hatte eine durchlöcherte Lunge.
Es ist ein gefährlicher Sport.
* Fliessende Popmusik *